incertidumbre en sudán tras el golpe
militar y la destitución del gobierno de
transición democrática miles de
sudaneses salieron a las calles para
protestar en contra de los militares y
la comunidad internacional y la onu
condenaron los hechos y pidieron la
liberación inmediata de los líderes de
puestos
francia condena con la mayor firmeza el
intento de golpe militar y sudán expreso
nuestro apoyo al gobierno de transición
sudanés y hago un llamado a la
liberación inmediata y al respeto a la
integridad del primer ministro y de los
dirigentes civiles sudán está en un
proceso de transición democrática desde
la caída de omar al bashir en 2019
liderado por el ejecutivo del primer
ministro
abraham doc ahora bajo arresto
domiciliario pero desde el golpe de
estado fallido del 21 de septiembre la
sociedad sudanés está dividida entre
aquellos a favor del gobierno civil y
los que respaldan una junta militar por
lo que la unión africana y fue un
llamado al diálogo
el presidente hace un llamado para que
se reanuden las conversaciones entre los
civiles y los militares en el marco de
la declaración política y el decreto
constitucional el presidente reafirma
que el diálogo y el consenso son el
único camino para salvar el país y su
transición democrática la situación ha
preocupado a varios países occidentales
como eeuu que pidió a sus ciudadanos que
no intenten abandonar sudán por el
momento
las fuerzas armadas de sudán han
anunciado que tienen el control del
gobierno se aconseja a los ciudadanos
estadounidenses que estén atentos a su
entorno y se refugien lo que incluye no
viajar a eeuu una inminente crisis
política que se suma a la gran depresión
económica en la nación africana